hi everyone my name is Michael and I
work in a company called hibernating
rhinos yeah rhinos that sleep we create
profilers for ramps but our main
business is this this is a no sequel
document database that we created from
scratch and I work on it for quite some
time now on internals I do low-level
stuff just some disability algorithms
and also as part of my job I do support
calls and post-mortem analysis so in
this talk I will I will share some some
interesting issues I've seen over the
years that our clients do not only with
no sequel databases but also with
relational databases and but in general
what I've seen people do with databases
but before the interesting stuff I have
a question for you how much queries do
you think typically a website would do
for page load anyone wants to guess
estimation how much nine five yeah
sometimes and sometimes more and
sometimes it's a lot more now this is by
the way this is from several months ago
this is not something old and yeah if
this is an edge case but I've seen
websites do dozens of queries per page
load easily and there are not really
large sites so this is the problem
obviously one of the reasons why it's a
problem because each query and people
often do not think about it each query
has very large overhead a from
infrastructure point of view but also
from computational point of view now
in general this often comes to modeling
in relational databases modeling is
simple you just do normalize and there
is one true way of doing things and you
get end up with what you end up right so
all you can do is optimize and try to
you to use less queries in relation no
sequel databases usually it's about how
you approach the problem and how do you
model data this is something very
important that I often see in people
that migrate from using relational
databases to non relation that which is
not necessarily our database is they say
they stay in a mindset of normalizing of
treating the data in the same way they
did in relational databases this is I
think one of the biggest mistakes you
can do because you often you can make it
work what the performance will be a blue
small at best so what about it in
general that data modeling in no sequel
is something for a workshop at least one
full day workshop so I will try to make
it sure because I have lots of things to
say in a 60 plus slice to show and I
hope I will finish it all so the
normalization no sequel is not is not
something bad it is often expected and
why it's expected especially in document
graph databases that the principles of
modeling and in terms of supporting
features and functionality you cannot do
quote unquote joins easily so usually
you won't be able to treat relationships
the same way you're doing relational
databases and in general know in no
sequel but bed or incorrect data
modeling that does not fit your problem
domain means more queries because you
need to make up for it now what should
you do would you should analyze your
problem domain and
plan your queries and your indexes and
what so on but I'm getting ahead of
myself also there is another thing about
the normalization
it's about point in time that's what I
usually call it and there is an
interesting story that I can tell that
highlights this the by the way this is
an actual story that happen in Israel
where I live in work young woman after
getting shortly after getting married
went with her husband to get a mortgage
they wanted to buy a house and the bank
said as you would expect please bring us
for payment slips to see what kind of
salary we'll get and we'll decide okay
they did they brought the the needed
papers and they see that her last name
she had her new supposedly last name for
the last five years what do you think
has happened and she was married couple
of months before this event what do you
think has happened
normalize data there was a bug in a
payment system that the the personal
details was normalized and as soon as
she changed her last name
it was retroactively Li changed all the
way since she started working there so
essentially when you think about Neda
normalization you can think about it as
kind of snapshot of the situation you
had during that specific time and more
often than not this is welcome
especially for financial information for
example if you think about invoices and
are in pretty much all countries there
is a retention policy how much time you
need to keep the invoices and let's say
invoice has is on the name of a company
named X right and let's say that two
years after the invoice was created the
company is bought and sold and changes
name so you does not make sense to
change the company name with the invoice
right so the normalization as you can
see is not always the best thing to do
so a couple of things that could also a
couple things that we can do about it
this is something I've seen oft often
over overlooked various realms and
various database such as ours a
shameless plug I know have an ability to
do something that usually called future
queries which essentially accumulate
several queries and group them in one
request this will sound using something
like this will allow you to drastically
and often very drastically less than the
amount of queries you do when you send
them to a database now let's see
something else let's think let's assume
we have a simple task we want to fetch
stuff that was ordered let's say for
last week right so we use entity
framework we open our Northwind model
I'm pretty sure anyone hasn't seen it
can you raise the hand anyone didn't see
the northen model okay so it's a demo
microsoft's demo database to just play
around this microphone sequel server
essentially it's data set of a something
like online store right so we fetch the
orders in fairly obvious manner and then
if we take a look at the things we see
something like this again lots of
queries just for relatively simple tasks
right what happened if you take a look
at the code we fetched for each order we
iterate for essentially we are supposed
to do a left join that would to do what
what you do that's what would you do if
you create the database directly right
so essentially what we did we fetched
each order separately and then query it
over and over again this is something
called select and plus one problem it's
actually an on T pattern and this is
another mistake that I've seen come over
and over again what exactly a mistake
it's about the more an anti-pattern but
it's directly related to the huge amount
of queries that we see quite often the
large amount of queries is something
like you fetch all the categories and
then fetch all the numbers in each
category you know this for example in
Amazon website you have a amount of
items for each category or something
like that
iíve seen implementations that do
exactly that they do four for each loop
and query the database in each loop
right so if you take a look closer at
entity framework features this can be
easily fixed you just tell the entity
for work that you want to fetch all the
details so together with an order
alright so if you take a look at the
traffic it will do something like this
so instead of n queries where n is
amount of orders you'll to make two
queries so essentially it's best to
invest time when you're dealing with
databases in general to take a look at
the features that aimed at preventing
antipatterns like select n plus 1 that's
not the only on T pattern so for sequel
servers is fairly it's it's it's fairly
understandable just do a left join and
you make sure not to do too much queries
for relational data for non-relational
databases it's a bit more complicated as
and as I said it's about the questions
you want to ask so such solutions depend
heavily on how do you model data for
example this is a JSON document and by
document databases by the way I don't
mean Word and PDFs I mean JSON files
because that's the JSON document because
that's usually how you
represent a variation of JSON or Beason
for example it's how you represent
documents so this is an example of how
you would model an order if you knew
that you will have to make something
like that queries I've shown you earlier
you just embed a collection of order
details inside of the document as I said
the normalization right and if you think
about it it makes sense because joints
and splitting the data during
normalization and in general the whole
relational database till it was invented
back then when storage was extremely
extremely expensive and developers time
was nothing in relation to hardware
costs so relational model in general was
invented to solve problems that were
that developed software had about 50
years ago so what do you expect in
general the first thing that we should
remember when we look at databases the
database API Sandow Rams and when you
talk about databases and think about
that way functionality it's only facade
and very thin facade that behind it it
has lots of moving parts and if you and
if you do not take into account some of
the moving parts there are maybe gocha's
here is an example of a Gocha that is
not in relational database let's take
him on got that MongoDB so if we have a
order like that and we want to you know
we need to query by city or by country
in if anywhere close right we want to
filter by city over by country right so
that's that's nice so what do we do we
take a look at and we see that we
can make indexes by by this certain
fields right make sense so we create an
index that will cover both of those
fields
and then require it by city that's how
MongoDB quarry look like looks like
quiet by city and we see that some that
it's go okay queries by index and
everything is fine then we query by
country and then we see something like
this now this is bad but before I
explain why this is bad let's take a
look at this in some databases and I
mean no sequel databases index terms
essentially prefixes so if you take to
make five fields by the way in
relational databases is roughly the same
if you take a look at the indexes you
will see that all the terms that you add
the fields to so we index it in country
this this will be one one large key that
that it's fields essentially just to
each other so if we queried by city it
was a prefix everything was fine right
and if we worried by the last part we
cannot find it because it's the last
part so the MongoDB was forced to source
by collection in other types of
databases and leucine leucine is a very
good example of such storage and it's
routine it's not exactly databases
storage engine by the way can you raise
the hand who heard about leucine leucine
dotnet oh okay nice more people and
thought because we've seen is relatively
unknown internet space leucine is
originated from Java actually in.net
there is a port that's called as you
would expect to seen dotnet is a very
good and very efficient querying engines
indexing engine and if you have heard
about elasticsearch and solar they all
usually seen behind the scenes rev in DB
also uses it but free v DB database so
there is another type of index that
stores the indie feel separately and in
this way for example in leucine based
query if you make an
index by on those two fields it won't
matter if you query one or the another
on both because it just fetches first
one then two then whatever fields and
intersects or dozen is any needed set
based operations in them
so in general collections collection
table scan it's a linear operation right
so if you have a huge amount of data it
will cost you and it will be cost you a
lot of time in production because that's
where you have lots of data Joel Spolsky
one of the founders stock overflow
summarized it pretty well because
abstractions and database is just an
abstraction for a bunch of algorithms
for indexing and storing in querying
there are all leaky and some abstraction
leaks can cause performance problems and
often that's the des the root cause of
when when when software roles do not
take into account abstraction leaks that
that's when performance problems start
with databases in general but not but
implementation details such as how
indexes work is not the only thing I
will talk about so another question take
a look at those queries and anyone wants
to say if they are different or know
anyone under the hood I mean I know the
syntax is different anyone wants to try
and guess
very different databases okay so the
answer is no they are not really
different because they all go to index
ideally unless of course it's a table
scan but it's an edge case which should
not happen in any case so in general
indexes work like this so if you have
some data to index so you just
essentially write for each search term
you each you write a pointer where it
happens right of course essentially very
very simple idea sometimes it's called
reverse index I'm not sure why but
anyway and indexes are usually
implemented as a three typically because
sometimes it's other data structures are
such astray and looking up the indexes
logarithm complexity why do I try is a
key length complexity so if you need
something more how high-performance is a
nice thing to use and if we take into
account a relatively simple query like
this and this is a revenue bigquery for
those who and you most likely don't
recognize the syntax is serving the
bigquery yeah the complexity even for
such trivial query and in any database
this will be trivial query is not so
trivial right so we search for one field
write that search for another then we
need to intersect them right so
essentially it's a linear operation
intersection so it's about the size of
the query and for relational databases
this is even more interesting because in
addition to where clauses you add a cost
of joins which I mentioned already they
were costly but are very very costly
especially especially for large
databases and in production you only
have a lot of databases if you don't
then you don't care about performance it
will be fast anyway
now and usually queries in production
look like this can you think about the
complexity of something like this and
I'm not talking about where clauses
which only add to complexity so
essentially will have a complexity
usually Oh too much so what what can we
do about it usually and the best thing
to do is proper indexing in relational
databases is more because they are more
prevalent so it's more more
understandable what we should do we
should properly set up indexes we should
optimize queries we should not do any
unnecessary joints that's and in
non-sequel except for proper modeling
which we talk about indexing planning is
extremely important because if you don't
plan indexes properly you either you can
end up for example whose collection
scans for databases was it were indexes
our sensually search by prefix or you
can have inefficient indexes for
databases that run indexes in a
background for example CouchDB fanned
mistake and then they run indexes
synchronously in separate threads so
i've seen data and we also do that in
ravi DB so for example I've seen indexes
and sorry I have seen databases with 300
indexes that run in the background and
and considering that thread pools are
finite what's the performance they think
of indexing was not very good so we can
conclude that complexity is also
something that obstructed by databases
and complexity is you should at least
invest some thought about complexity of
queries and what you do is databases
because more often than not just
reducing ten joins to three join can
improve order of magnitude I remember on
my first job I had a Hugh
a huge sequel query with about
30-something joins which was running
about four minutes and I reduced it to
three joins and it was running in 300
milliseconds so that's quite a change
yeah after some index optimizations also
but you understand what I mean now let's
take a look at another interesting thing
this is an actually this is an actual
support call that they took a client had
multiple tenants or databases on one
server right I had no issue with
hardware so no limits on memory and
stuff like that and it took for a very
long time to load the process and the
client thought it was hanging up so a
question is can you think what what what
will be the root cause of something like
this anyone wants to try no one well the
answer is very simple when you have lots
of databases and you start up the server
they all start reading from the hard
drive because they need to do some
memory mapping some fetching from from
database and memory mapping which is
usually what databases use starts
fetching pages to memory and obviously
you saturate I'll Drive
and the client had it's a bit more than
200 databases on the same storage which
usually usually works fine because they
were accessed constantly but for a very
short period of time but during load up
all of them in the same time started
loading so you can imagine the house
storage was worse straining another
thing that more often than not people
when they look at the databases
they do not take into account
environment environmental constraints
such as storage such as Network such as
even memory or or CPU threads whatever
is finite and databases are not magic
magic black boxes and they will struggle
so here's another riddle why do you
think this would happen
query that has not much results core
results right and it takes very long
time to complete let's say five seconds
I don't remember the numbers exactly but
500 looks like a very good number so
anyone wants to try and guess the answer
is very simple
actually yes the what good guess but
it's even simpler than that anyone else
no no it was it was the equivalent of a
select top hundred no scanning
whatsoever was involved in this anyone
else what yep
did it was a document database and each
document was tens of megabytes of size
and to be more exact network bandwidth
but that's the right idea network
bandwidth so as you can imagine hundred
documents each one each between five and
ten megabytes of JSON would would cost
something like this because the time
that was spent on the server actually
fetching the query was in the in the
milliseconds that dozens sometimes in
the hundreds
milliseconds now regarding large
document sizes there is one more thing
that usually when you take a look at no
sequel database which is a document or
graphs because graphs are usually
document databases with relationships
that are first-class citizen but under
the hood usually graph databases have
document that the basis is how they do
they do serialization
it may sound trivial but serialization
actually is a very big problem to tackle
think about like this you have a
document which is of unknown form or
shape right JSON with a known form shape
need to go over all its fields
recursively right you need to do lots of
allocations you need to do lots of you
need to do lots of recursion because
sometimes the recursion is very deep
right so I have seen and in our database
for example before we changed how we do
things I've seen just the server's Asian
self take about between 30 and 40
percent of application time all right
this is a lot and I'm not talking about
garbage collection pauses that are
caused by excessive allocations and we
were using json dot net which is variant
well-known a very performant library but
it makes lots of allocations I mean lots
of them so one of the solutions that
usually database vendors take they use
some sort of pointer arithmetic to get
to the point so for example we
implemented our own JSON format that
uses that stores JSON with special table
kind of like fire allocation table but
stores the offsets of each property each
field inside the JSON and this way we
can access the fields without allocating
memory in our databases that are doing
something similar from what I've seen is
MongoDB for example so size does matter
also for document document sizes not
only for net
but also for how databases do things and
sir ization from what I've seen is
something that not many people think
about it and quite quite often it's
critical for any any application so this
is something that I've seen do a lot of
good when you deal with databases with
any database what I will usually do I
take a look at its traffic's at certain
times during stress testing do a load
testing if possible also during
production because there is no way
around it
database is a application that has a
client in a server right and again
usage patterns of databases are very and
usually I'd mistrust any bench for
example I usually mistrust by any
benchmarking benchmarking that compare
between databases because some databases
perform well in certain use case another
use case the dark rap and vice-versa so
don't believe benchmarks don't believe
even your eyes use tools to prove to
prove that you are doing good things
that you have known any inefficiency
that your queries are doing fine because
for example databases that use HTTP I
can change this plug but I work on the
database so I'm biased
reven DB has uses REST API so you can
you can debug latencies and what what
the client-side sends your fiddler but
other databases have profilers or other
database I have tools to inspect both
the queries and latencies and
performance of network based component
so this is something that I cannot
stress enough this I realize it may
sound trivial but I've seen often people
just don't do this and usually I will
even sing couple of times people do not
set up even monitoring
to see if there I have problems or
inefficiencies in the network which I
cannot understand why but anyway another
thing that I have mentioned it before
but resources this is something that we
need to mention explicitly and I will
explain as by an example how does it how
does it work so for example we have very
nice feature which is where m 11 DB so
you can get real-time notifications to
data that you subscribe on so if some
data changes the subscriber client will
get notification that something was that
something happened right so this sounds
nice and you can implement lots of nice
things with something like this and
we're not the only database that has
something like this for example again
MongoDB has something similar and such
feature unfortunately gets overlooked a
lot and I'm sure you can even now see
how it can help you with implementing
stuff but this this is a real case that
we have seen there is a support call a
production website was opening once per
page load a subscription so what do you
think happened what what what's the
consequence of using something like this
until rate that's nice right you have a
mechanism that will notify you in real
time that something happens and you can
update your UI and we will and you can
to notification something has changed
right what do you think and can you try
to guess what would happen if something
opens once per page load
one of the things socket exhaustion
that's actually what happened with that
client but that's not the only thing
depending on load some more things that
can happen it was soaking exhaustion
because because it opens TCP socket from
the client to the server opens
persistent TCP socket which is
constantly kept alive right and on the
server side it opens a special thread
when the subscription is activated
because it's not active all the time
that that and the thread listens to the
changes sounds simple right but thread
pool threads are also something that is
finite and thread pool trades are used
depending on a database can be used for
example for accepting requests so a
database would exhaust the thread pool
can just refuse to get to request to
accept queries right and it can happen
just because under some load spike and
then under very bad scenario it can even
trigger some other failures and stuff
start time mounting and it will be very
nice calling 3m now in general special
care should be taken to look at Ted pool
connections of sockets so whatever
communication protocol your database had
with the client and bottlenecks
environmental bottlenecks as well we
have mentioned was storage and network
bottlenecks those usually pop up with
support calls and usually pop up when
you have inefficiencies in in
performance so things for example here
here's a nice example of a storage
bottleneck what it was it wasn't
apparent right we had a client that had
a cluster of databases and the cluster
of databases was using son SSD drives
very fast it was nice right and the we
implemented cluster using
protocol and this means that and this
means that when there is there is a need
for for some storage capacity when
writing because it stores a state
machine because consider protocol is a
protocol to is a way to propagate a
state over the cluster and so all the
cluster agrees on certain state right so
and this state is persisted and the
cluster was failing for at random times
right and then the interesting thing is
that they usually did everything was
very fast right and during peak times
the cluster sometimes failed during peak
traffic what happened was the Sun drive
all the cluster all sitting on shared
SSDs so when one of the nodes was
overloaded all the other nodes had much
less storage capacity to work with and
disk latency fell fell fell momentarily
and that caused the race condition to
make stuff fail now if I didn't know
what happens under the hood if I didn't
know for example how the clustering
protocol worked and if I didn't know how
the underlying things worked I I'm not
so sure if I could have found the
solution to and at least the root cause
to do this issue so it's it's very
important to take a look at those
resources to take a look at how they're
used by by your database whatever
database you use and just invest some
time into peeking under the hood of
databases now there is another finite
resource it's not really a resource
right but it's finite already
concurrency now about concurrency there
is some times I sometimes see
people who just not so sure what it
means so I will at least explain a
little bit before optimistic concurrency
is very simple you assume that you won't
have too much contention on your data so
you have very small log duration only
and if you even have logs all you do it
with kind x time pro version or whatever
buzz word / term your database users and
essentially it's it comes down to update
this record if nobody has updated the
CSI since I've taken it to update right
so a a update request comes takes the
query takes the record does whatever
needs to do with it transaction for
example and then tries to write it down
and sees if nobody has updated it in the
in the meantime right so that's until
very nice but what with what if we have
several transactions and one
transactions very very short and we have
lots of other transactions which edit
the same data or try to edit and are
longer what do you think will happen it
del just gets all big right and now
multiply it by thousand let's say you
have thousands requests per second it's
reasonable load for for for a website
and you will see why optimistic
concurrency is optimized only when you
have very small contention to the data
right if you have lots of contention
then you should go to pessimistic
concurrency which is essentially what
often happened in relational databases
you have a transaction that changes some
row so it locks the row you have
sometimes the lock is escalates on table
for example
so it's more geared towards lots of
contention and rolling back and retry
and transaction is much much much more
expensive than just waiting for it to
win decide the database now the
interesting part that each such query is
a thread usually it's taken from tadpole
now what will happen if you have
exhausted your thread pool for example
by using some other feature that is also
straight pool you'll get very
interesting things were very interesting
balance because tried Foley's as I
mentioned used by several multiple
features of single database so
essentially I like chart to chart stuff
so this is something that can summarize
this to meet pessimistic and optimistic
concurrency it's a trade-off and there
is no correct way of going about
concurrency or thinking about it it all
depends on your use cases and on stuff
that that you do on how do you need to
query database how did you do updates so
in general you shouldn't keep
transaction open for too long because
very long transaction they will either
keep other or lock data and keep others
from updating it or they will cause
others to increase the change that they
will get rolled back because because of
the whatever other short transaction
updated the data so this is it
and I'll I'd love to answer some
questions
yeah there is a link to open to our
source code if you be curious again
you're invited to take a look - rayvin
DB source code anyone questions
so I go this is it thank you